le sport et ce week-end
idyllique pour les clubs tours enjaux le
TFC prend la tête de National 3 le TVB
lui large vainqueur du sommet de Liga à
Saint-Nazaire en revanche la déabloa
basket replonge après une nouvelle
défaite on voit ça avec Romain de ville
on élite de basket la diabloa ne rédite
pas l'exploit de la semaine précédente
face à Levallois grâce à un money time
de folie les basketteurs blazois 5
lignes face à Gravelines Dunkerque Scorp
final 89 92 la DA passe à l'avant
dernière place au classement
en Liga de volley-ball le TVB voyage
bien à sa Nazaire malgré l'absence pour
blessure de corridge et aracajou les
volailleurs touranjo s'imposent 3 7 à 0
et garde leur première place du
championnat les hommes de Marcello
francoviaque retrouvent la Ligue des
champions mercredi avec un déplacement
périlleux après des Richardson en
fédéral 2 de rugby une affaire de
pénalité a scellé la victoire de l'US
tour face à Mallemort 15-9 5 pénalités à
3 c'est le score final de la rencontre
l'UST et troisième de sa poule de
Fédérale 2 dans les autres résultats les
remparts de Tours s'imposent 3-2 face à
Épinal en D1 de hockey sur glace tandis
qu'en national une de basket des
Tourangeaux trop tendres père d'arène
91-85 mais s'accroche à leur dixième
place au classement